and there was war in heaven Michael and
his angels fought against the Dragon and
the dragon fought and his angels and
prevailed not and the Great Dragon was
cast out that old serpent called the
devil and Satan the accuser which
deceiveth the whole world he was cast
out into the earth and his angels were
cast out with him
well he trained kids for years in
self-defense now a martial arts
instructor is defending himself in court
accused of sexually assaulting a student
[Music]
you really believe in magic in Chinese
black magic yes oh absolutely
she's too serious about this and
monsters and ghosts as well as well oh
sure and sorcery and I suppose that you
expect me to believe in sorcery as well
of course why because it's real how can
I know that mr. Shen Wow yes how help me
out here please
huh see there was nothing but that's how
it always begins very small
the floodgates of Eastern mysticism and
new-age thought were opened in the West
through cinema and literature focused on
a generation searching for its identity
with the Cultural Revolution Woodstock
in the Beatles martial arts yoga and the
introduction of Transcendental
Meditation found a growing acceptance
among baby boomers television shows and
films such as David Carradine's kung fu
The Green Hornet Billy Jack and Bruce
Lee's epic brought the mystical powers
of the martial arts into the homes and
lives of millions of Americans and a
country once historically Christian in
background and belief began to flirt
with the ideologies of the far east and
little did we realize the price we would
pay for stepping on to this enchanted
ground during the 1970's and 80's
martial arts became mainstream with the
introduction of full contact karate and
kickboxing to the public the martial
arts were now being promoted not only is
self-defense but as a sport as health
and fitness and even as a family
activity martial arts Tai Chi and yoga
classes begins springing up in YMCAs and
health clubs across the US and Hollywood
in the printed page brought secrets of
the Far East within reach of the
imaginations of millions of Americans
while promising them disciplined self
confidence self control and self esteem
during the 1990s Chinese masters with
their internal arts of Tai Chi ba gua
Cheng Yi and ki Gong began publishing
books which revealed the methods of
attaining these wants secret abilities
of the martial art legends and there is
now a growing interest in the spiritual
powers and practices of these men of the
East even many celebrities and
politicians have revealed their active
participation in these and other
mystical Eastern arts today the martial
arts seductively blended with
metaphysics and psychology has
begun to take on a more scientific
facade once traditionally secret arts
are now being taught as the means to
achieve not only personal protection but
self-healing self-awareness and
emotional regeneration self empowerment
has become the god of this age a web of
Eastern philosophy and mysticism is
being spread in an ever-increasing
attempt to capture the hearts and minds
of this last generation through
Hollywood the film and entertainment
industry is weaving an illusion of the
martial arts being both scientific as
well as spiritual and it is this blend
of science and spiritism which will
prove to be the final of mega of
apostasy which was foretold by the
apostles of Jesus Christ
I put the force into the movies in order
to try to awaken a certain kind of
spirituality in young people more belief
in God than a belief in any particular
you know religious system I mean the
real question is to ask the question
because if you if you haven't enough
interest in the mysteries of life to ask
the questions
is there a God roots or not a god that's
that's for me the worst thing that can
happen you know if you ask a young
person is their God they say I don't
know you know I think you should have an
opinion about that the question must be
asked a belief in what God who hath
ascended up into heaven or descended
down from above who hath established all
the ends of the earth what is his name
and what is his son's name if thou canst
tell and what is this mystery which
Lucas and others are spending billions
to introduce to the youth of our
generation let no man deceive you by any
means for the mystery of iniquity doth
already work according to the Chinese
classic The Tao Te Ching the Dow is like
a well
used but never used up it is like the
eternal void filled with infinite
possibilities it is hidden but always
present the dow doesn't take sides it
gives birth both to good and evil the
dow is called the great mother
empty yet inexhaustible it gives birth
to infinite worlds it is always present
within you and you can use it any way
you want this spiritual energy called
the dow or universal life force is
symbolized by the mystical figure of the
yin and yang and it is through this
merging of light with darkness these two
opposite yet supposedly equal powers
that harmony and the dow is manifest and
spiritual gifts and abilities are said
to be achieved this description is
identical to that of the power used by
the Jedi and Sith warriors in the Star
Wars film series this very same power is
also called by them the force and it is
this force of light and darkness of good
and evil which lucifer claims to be it
is this spirit and power which has been
worshipped by every occult and pagan
religion since the dawn of time Albert
Pike the author of morals and Dogma
states this belief in unmistakable terms
yes Lucifer is God and unfortunately
atone I or the Lord Jesus is also God
for the eternal law is that there is no
light without shade no beauty without
ugliness no white without black for the
absolute can only exist as to God's
darkness being necessary to light simply
put pure philosophic religion is the
belief in Lucifer the equal of Adonai
but Lucifer god of light and God of good
is struggling for humanity against
Adonai the god of darkness and evil and
professing themselves to be wise they
became fools for if therefore the light
that is in thee be darkness how great is
that darkness according to both Asian
and occult philosophy this force or
energy is said to dwell within all
matter the rocks the trees the planets
animals and every human being and
although hidden it is said to be only
awaiting to be awakened an awakening
which is achieved through the practice
of Eastern meditation breathing
techniques mantra chanting visualization
hypnosis and countless other occult
practices it is this spiritual energy
which all Eastern religions credit is
the true source of their power although
this mysterious power is called by
different names in every culture its
principles and manifestations are always
the same for what is known as Chi by the
ancient Chinese it's called key in the
Japanese art of Aikido while to the
Hindu this same power is known as prana
to the Polynesian people it is called
mana or mana energy and by many New Age
practitioners in the West this spiritual
power is called Oregon vibrational or
subtle energy and this same spiritual
energy today is being used and promoted
by New Age gurus worldwide to martial
artists across the world the cultivation
control and demonstration of this energy
is considered the high
and most sought after ability she is
said to be manifest through harmonizing
both positive and negative forces of the
universe within the human body this
energy is then demonstrated by martial
artists in countless ways stone brick or
board-breaking
iron body exhibitions performing
seemingly impossible feats of acrobatics
skilled withstanding extremes of
temperature exhibiting superhuman
strength speed and explosive power and
this same mysterious energy which is
used by disciples and masters of these
combative arts is also demonstrated by
ki Gong and Reiki practitioners by
acupuncturist acupressure Asst Tai Chi
masters yoga gurus and new-age holistic
healers to many this power is called the
God spark or cosmic consciousness but
regardless of its name this esoteric
power is from one and the same source
that old serpent the devil in the
philosophy of yin and yang nothing is of
itself considered to be inherently evil
or wrong everything is said to be good
so long as it is used to maintain
balance of the DAO and the greater good
of the universe this then is the martial
arts most subtle deception for according
to this philosophy that which is called
God owes its very existence to the
joining of light with darkness but the
word of the Lord assures us that God is
light and in him is no darkness at all
in this pagan philosophy there are no
absolutes or as Aleister Crowley stated
do as thou wilt shall be the whole of
the law and this poor man who was a
legend and an icon in the music and film
industry spent the final hours of his
life in the state of hopelessness dread
and fear
in these teachings truth becomes merely
the point of one's own perspective and
the Serpent's whisper hath God really
said can be as verily heard today as it
was so long ago and the shadow of doubt
is cast upon Jehovah's Holy Word woe
unto them that call evil good and good
evil that put darkness for light and
light for darkness to the law and to the
testimony of his spirit if they speak
not according to this word it is because
there is no light in them the symbols of
the tiger and dragon are as ancient as
the martial arts itself and familiar to
all styles they are synonymous with the
yin and yang of Eastern mysticism and
philosophy but what few understand is
the role which these two symbols play
and the spiritual significance which is
revealed when joining them as one while
the tiger represents men's physical
strength and power the earthly carnal
and unregenerate harped man's will to
conquer it is the dragon which stands as
the symbol of the Prince of the powers
of the air those principalities and
powers of darkness which now work it in
the children of disobedience it is this
spirit of the Dragon which the Masters
of the martial arts hold in such
reverence and awe and it is this power
which is sought above all others while
most Western instructors will emphatic
ly deny any involvement with the occult
religions of the east when we watch the
practices of these men and women and
compare their arts and the fruits
thereof with the Word of God there are
serious questions which arise as we this
training is hard training
it developed your mental faculties it
turned into wire and killer instinct we
develop him as a wire it is common for
these teachers to say that they are able
to divorce the physical arts from their
spiritual roots but according to high
level martial artists and masters this
is a great deception when one looks
closely at the religious background of a
Styles founder you will discern the
spirit which inspired or inspirited that
style and which influences its forms
techniques and methods of training the
very spiritual DNA of a martial style
can never be separated or severed from
its practice for out of the heart the
mouth speaks and through physical
actions the spirit is manifest the word
of Almighty God says by their fruits ye
shall know them for how can two walk
together except they be agreed our very
actions bear witness to the powers or
God which we live for serve and obey a
Christian instructor joined to a pagan
style is spiritual adultery
unfaithfulness and apostasy
I'm 100% Jesus God can't see my heart
people misunderstood think oh how a
creature can find me
yeah for sure
I wish you could find me a Christian can
go to war accretion control we're
Christians we not differently just
Christians and I don't see nothing wrong
with that but do these thoughts agree
with the word of the Living God and if
this is correct then why does the Lord
tell us through his Apostle John that he
which saith he abideth in Christ God
himself also so to walk and live even as
Jesus lived
they call themselves warriors literally
fighting the good fight of faith never
mind that the Gospel of Matthew quotes
Jesus is saying if anyone slaps you on
the right cheek turn to him the other
also because tonight you're going to
meet a group of Christians who say that
by striking an opponent well they're
striking a blow for the Lord Ryan Owens
has an encore presentation from our
series faith matters
[Applause]
[Music]
fight breaks out
but this isn't your grandfather's bar
fight then as soon as I type you let's
press yes and some of these fighters
give Bible beaters father we just thank
you for the opportunity to go out
tonight and to train and compete a whole
new meaning the line of distinction
between professed Christians and the
ungodly is now hardly distinguishable as
Christians there are times where you
take shots that's where the Bible gives
you your training
[Music]
to get all the time I don't look like
the typical pastor and that's okay
there's actually cool verse in the Bible
says be weary when all men speak well of
you if everybody loves you you're doing
something wrong my god you have called
us to a fight when Preston came up with
the idea of having a fight club in the
church it was an easy thing to say yes
to tough guys need Jesus to do you guys
like to see me fight another pastor
we'll just be a couple of god-fearing
men punching each other in the face
[Music]
tonight we got a fight and then without
my dues tomorrow we go to church how
many are yet walking in darkness not
realizing the high calling upon their
lives in Christ Jesus and this ain't
love at the end of the day is about
reaching people with the gospel
regardless of what you do to introduce
them into relationship with Jesus Christ
now go through jump right yeah for he
has promised us that an elder must be
blameless the husband of one wife
vigilant sober not self-willed not soon
to anger but a lover of good men just
holy and temperent in all things an
elder must not be given to wine not a
striker but patient and not a brawler
holding fast the faithful word so that
he may be able by sound doctrine and
instruction to exhort and convince the
gainsayers
[Music]
but the question is often asked what
about self-defense and what about the
physical training methods of these arts
can I not be a Christian and yet still
training these arts without their
spiritual influences it is through
actions repeated that habits are formed
habits which form our character and it
is by character that our destiny for
time and eternity is decided if we are
practicing daily to block and counter
what will become our natural response
when meeting confrontation or opposition
and what is the character which these
arts import to their students when pure
knuckles meet pure flesh
that's pure karate no matter who
executes it or whatever style is
involved when two Tigers fight one is
certain to be maimed and one to die
jiu-jitsu is the gentle art it is the
art where a small man is going to prove
to you no matter how strong you are no
matter how mad you get that you're going
to have to accept defeat
that's what Brazilian jiu-jitsu is if we
fight for money
I'll stop hitting you when you ask me to
if we fight for honor
I'll stop hitting you when I feel like
the heart of karate is real fighting
there can be no proof without real
fighting better to be a tiger for a day
than a sheep for a lifetime
many parents enroll their children in
the martial arts with the hopes of them
learning self-defense self-control and
discipline but is this the reality of
these practices do the training and
teachings of these Eastern arts really
lead to greater obedience and submission
to a parent's instruction in the Word of
God do students of these arts typically
grow closer in their walk with the Lord
Jesus Christ as they progress in rank or
do we see another character being formed
one of pride of Independence and
rebellion to Authority for even hereunto
were ye called because Christ also
suffered for us leave
an example that he should follow in his
steps he who did no sin neither was
guile and deceit found in his mouth who
when he was reviled he reviled and
retaliated not again when he suffered he
threatened not but committed himself
unto the judgment of him that judgeth
righteously dearly beloved I say avenge
not yourselves but rather give place to
wrath for it is written vengeance is
mine I will repay saith the Lord
therefore if thine enemy is hungry feed
him if he is thirsty give him to drink
for in so doing thou shalt heap coals of
fire upon his head and his conscience
shall be burnt therefore be not overcome
by evil but overcome evil with good the
martial arts are being marketed today as
a family activity but the tradition
behind this idea would shock most
students and parents if they were told
the truth when they joined traditional
Asian martial arts styles were based on
family or clans secrets of warfare these
secrets were not allowed to be spoken of
or shared outside the dojo or home of
the master we will look at one such
legendary founder of the arts so that
you may see and understand the spiritual
influences which are working behind the
scenes the man's name is Tatsu Shima
Bucca he is the founder of ition Roux
karate it was during a vision given him
in the 1950s that she mabuki saw the
principles of his art revealed and under
the inspiration of the goddess Megami he
founded his style of karate by the
direct instruction of this spirit the
Okinawan master drew a picture of what
he had seen in his vision which later
was duplicated as the logo and symbol of
the ition roof style and under the
oversight of one of his disciples the
artwork took form
and the symbol of his art can now be
seen adorning tens of thousands of
karate uniforms and dojos worldwide look
closely at the figures represented in
the emblem of his art the woman is an
unnatural blending or amalgamation of
the human female and a serpent above her
right shoulder is the image of a great
red dragon and three prominent stars the
female image is shown rising up out of
the abyss and seated upon the stormy
seas the symbolism is too exact to be
mere coincidence come hither I will show
thee the judgment of the great [__]
that sitteth upon many waters and I saw
a woman sit upon a scarlet coloured
Beast full of names of blasphemy having
seven heads and ten horns and the waters
which thou sawest where the [__]
sitteth are people's multitudes nations
and tongues and the woman which thou
sawest is that great city which reigneth
over the kings of the earth
the original title given by the founder
for this symbol was ition rune no Megami
or the goddess of ition ruh megami mae
means woman Comi orgami is the Japanese
word for Shinto deity or God ition ruh
ish or Ichi means one chief or first
Shen means spirit or heart ruh means
Tatsu dragon or way the goddess of the
first spirit dragon even the name of the
founder Tatsu Shi mabuki was symbolic of
the Styles ultimate goals and purpose
Tatsu literally means in Japanese the
dragon man he was given this title in
honor of his enlightenment and
recognition by the pagan gods in the
founding of this art to him and the
initiated feud the final revelation of
Chandru karate is the way or path of you
19 as one the spirit of the dragon and
man and Shima bukas art is not the only
style which reveals its true spiritual
intent I Aikido the way of harmonizing
with spirit Hapkido the path or way of
unity with spirit
Chingy quan mind will and form boxing ba
gua Shan eight trigram or divination
palms in each of these martial arts real
power is obtained only by the transfer
of spiritual energy for it is through
the inspiration of the Masters gurus and
teachers which has passed down to their
disciples that the Dragon is working to
bring about his last great deception and
it is through these countless millions
of men women and innocent children which
strive in their training to imitate the
role of their instructor that an image
is truly being formed either we are
being daily transformed by the renewing
of our minds into the image of the Lord
Jesus Christ or we are being slowly
conformed and molded into the image of
this world and its first rebel leader
have you ever wondered why so many dojos
and martial studios require students to
remove their shoes when entering the
school or stepping on to the training
floor is it possible that these
practices reveal a deeper spiritual
significance than many have been led to
believe and the Lord God said unto Moses
draw not nigh hither put off thy shoes
from off thy feet for the place whereon
thou standest is holy ground are these
schools being used as the grounds upon
which to worship Eastern pagan deities
look at their very names in the Asian
languages and let us listen to their own
response dojo a place of the way - Aang
the place of enlightenment
traditionally the dojo is considered
sacred ground with its own special
etiquette to begin every student submits
unquestionably to their teacher
submission is often represented
symbolically by the simple ceremony of
bowing to the teacher whatever the floor
is made of be it cement carpet or an
expensive mat the way I present my
answer when the student asks why do we
take off our shoes is that the student
removes his shoes to yield to the
instructors right to lead the instructor
removes his shoes because he too yields
to a higher power the dojo is a
destination it is a place to go it is
sacred ground no one ends up in a dojo
by mistake for many of us it is like
coming home we bow to the front the
showman in honor of our ancestral
heritage then we bow to the sensei or
master as a gesture of respect for the
teacher in addition to being a teacher
of karate techniques the sensei is a
guide a guide to illuminate the path and
lead the way for the student the sensei
is the guiding light because the sensei
serves such an important role in shaping
a student's development
physically mentally and spiritually the
sensei must possess outstanding
qualifications and abilities the titles
of sensei and Sifu are Asian in origin
they refer to a teacher who has
dedicated his life to instructing his
pupils in the martial way but the Lord
Jesus Christ tells us be not called
rabbi for one is your master even Christ
and ye are all brethren and call no man
father upon the earth for one is your
father which is in heaven and neither be
ye called masters
for one is your master even Christ for
he that is greatest among you shall be
your servant
for whosoever shall exalt himself shall
be cast down but those that humble
themselves shall be exalted is not this
the very character which is seen in the
martial arts that of Pride and self
exaltation the spirit that I saw when I
accepted Jesus into my heart was
different that spirit was one of love it
was one of peace the spirit that I
received from the Masters and I trained
under some of the best in the world that
spirit was one of violence it was
different it was one of control it was
one of mastery over another person it
wasn't the same spirit in the Lord that
I could love that person for who they
were not for what I knew and what I
demanded of them so and that really is
the attitude of many people within the
martial arts they lord it over those who
are under them it becomes a superiority
problem it becomes a an issue that they
want control they do have control over
you in some sense of control and they
want to emulate their instructor and
they want to give they want to give that
person something that they received so
it's a spirit that is passed down from
generation to generation and each
succeeding generation either become
stronger or they quit one or the other
they're all looking for that power power
over people the power of violence and
they want to emulate that power in such
a way that that people will fear them
and it's the fear factor that most
people don't understand and is this not
the very character of Satan before the
fall from his exalted position in heaven
oh how art thou fallen from heaven o
Lucifer son of the morning star for thou
has said in thine heart I will ascend
a high will exalt my throne I will sit
upon the Mount of the congregation I
will be like the Most High then we look
and see the son of Almighty God as he
humbles himself and takes on the form of
a servant that of a mere man and we see
him as he battles with all the desires
of our fallen nature within his own
human flesh and as he cries out for
victory and strength in the Garden of
Gethsemane and he fell on his face and
prayed saying O my father if thou be
willing remove this cup from me
nevertheless not my will but thine be
done and the same Lord and sovereign
king who sweat great drops of blood
there in the garden fighting for you and
I is the same who spoke from the heights
of Sinai with words which shook the
earth like thunder thou shalt have no
other gods before me thou shalt not make
unto thee any graven image or any
likeness of anything that is in heaven
above or that is in the earth beneath or
that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them
nor serve and obey them even on the most
basic level the practice of the martial
arts contradicts not only the gospel of
Jesus Christ but also the very clear
instructions of his written word the
Lord God Jehovah Yahweh Elohim tells us
that we are not to bow in humility in
obedience nor in service to anyone in
place of our Creator for when man
chooses to serve and obey another he is
verily committing idolatry as if a
statue were standing right before him
the bow in ceremony is based on a Shinto
ritual banishing evil spirits and
inviting the presence of the gods
however in the context of training
students may think of this ritual as
banishing their own personal Deen
it's cleansing the mind of negative or
distracting thoughts and preparing for
training they may envision summoning
their best selves to rise to the
challenges of training and extract the
maximum benefit in understanding from
the teachings they are about to receive
the words spoken during the bow in and
bow out ceremony can be translated as in
every moment another chance for
enlightenment bowing to others is not
about a sign of submission but about
recognizing the spark of divinity in
another fellow human being
bowing is one of the most humble and
spiritual acts a human can perform it is
an action that simultaneously signifies
acceptance and a deep understanding of
and feeling toward its object
moreover through this action we cast
aside the narrow confines of the self
and we accept the energy of the universe
by bowing we are giving up ourselves to
the universe to give up ourselves means
to give up our dualistic ideas and
become one when you become one with
everything that exists you find the true
meaning of being
as we listen to these words are we not
once again hearing the whispers of the
serpent in Eden which said he shall not
surely die but ye shall be as gods but
thus saith the Lord God Almighty I have
yet reserved unto myself a remnant in
Israel which have not bowed their knee
to bow for sin is the faithless
transgression of my law and verily I say
unto you whosoever continue it in sin is
the slave of sin and the wages of sin is
death a diligent study will reveal the
true spiritual influences which these
masters receive for their styles often
while in a trance or a deep meditation
and worshiping their pagan deities and
it is this same spiritual influence
which is then passed down from Grand
Master's masters and disciples to their
students most people in the Western
Hemisphere failed to realize the strong
roles and family ties which are
prevalent in the eastern cultures a
Grand Master or founder is known as C
Joe or Sookie and this title declares
him to be the head of family in an order
style therefore when a student joins a
school they are taught through both
example and instruction to yield the
highest honor respect and obedience to
the head of their martial clan when a
master decides to teach a disciple he
not only takes on the role of a teacher
but also assumes the role of a parent
Chinese people hold teachers in very
high regard to begin every student
submits unquestionably to their teacher
they must be willing to empty their cup
of any previous misconceptions and to
accept the new teachings no matter how
disruptive they may be to their personal
worldview this is just one reason why it
is important to begin with a good
teacher submission is often represented
symbolically by the simple ceremony of
bowing to the teacher whether to the
instructor in the dojo or to that man's
master it is considered the highest
disrespect to fail to obey any given
instruction by this man a failure to
comply in the traditional arts often
even in lifestyle is frowned upon and
will hinder the student's progress in
training and the promotion of rank and
as each student surrenders their will in
obedience to their sensei or Sifu these
masters in turn also bow in homage
before the Grand Master and images of
the Styles founder each one surrendering
their will in order to achieve greater
skill and inspiration in their art and a
higher position on the steps of the
pyramid a spiritual hierarchy in the
martial arts every stone sent one upon
another and every rung in the ladder is
achieved by exalting self above others
every student in disciple bowing in
reverence and submission to the Masters
above and each one of these bowing to
the man enthroned upon the mountain
summit for the Lord Jesus Christ says
the words that I speak unto you they are
spirit and they are life to whom you
yield yourself servants to obey his
heart to you obey whether of sin unto
death or of obedience unto righteousness
and life and so it is that as men
listened to the voice of the great
deceiver and yield their bodies as
servants to obey Him
it is then that they become pawns in the
hands of one they do not see they become
the habitation of devils
and slaves to darkness and sin
[Music]
each and every master regardless of the
error or the place heard the call and
attained harmony with heaven and earth
there are many paths leading to the top
of Mount Fuji but there is only one
summit the divine is not something above
us it is in heaven it is in the earth it
is inside us the art of peace high
practice has room for each of the
world's eight million gods and I
cooperate with them all so to whom does
this man the Abba t' and head of shaolin
temple bow and pay homage and of whom
are the figures and images which
surround him it is they the fallen ones
the image of those angels cast down out
of heaven by the Lord Jesus Christ from
whom this man receives his power and
abilities and what is the sanctuary
where this man worships before his pagan
deities the figures which you now see
are those found in a shrine known at the
Shaolin Temple as maha vari or the hall
of the three buddhas it is here that the
temple monks direct their worship but
who is the central figure and what is
the symbolic gesture which we see formed
by his right hand why do we see the very
same symbols which are associated with
Wicca black magic secret societies and
even the rock and roll industry also
being displayed with Hindu Buddhist and
Taoist idols some dating back more than
a thousand years is there a connection
are the same spirits which work behind
the scenes in one also influencing the
other and who is the bearded figure
which we see standing at his far outer
right his name is Bodhi Dharma or damo
which in Chinese literally means hairy
devil he is the patron saint of the
Shaolin Temple and Chan Buddhism he is
also the 28th in a long lineage of
disciples and teachers springing from
the founder of the Hindu Buddhist
Bodhidharma brought his revised version
of Hinduism from India to China in the
year 4 64 AD and legend tells us that it
was he who taught the monks of Shaolin
Temple the methods of physical movement
combined with meditation to enhance
their spiritual abilities through Hindu
breathing exercises and yoga mantra
chanting visualisation techniques and
kata
the monks were said to develop almost
supernatural psychic and physical powers
so we see that it was not the strict
diet of rice and vegetables which gave
rise to the Shaolin monks notoriety in
the world of combative arts neither is
it simply due to their rigorous training
regime that these Buddhist warriors in
their temple are known as the world's
birthplace and source of all martial
styles but their unique abilities are
credited to a more elusive and spiritual
power something working subtly into
things they were taught by this Hindu
priest after his death legend has it
that the monks of Shaolin found a set of
writings that were left hidden within
the temple wall or his tomb in which he
gave detailed yet cryptic instructions
written in his own native Sanskrit
tongue on the way and its power
exercises which would enable the Masters
and their future disciples to reach
nirvana and enlightenment
it is these writings known as the muscle
tendon changing mario brainwashing
classics which are revered among martial
artists worldwide and it is these which
formed the foundation of all modern
martial forms kata ki Gong and training
there are many who begin training in
these Eastern arts and say they will
practice only the physical disciplines
laying their Eastern spiritual
influences to the side but according to
the founders grandmasters and gurus of
these arts this is not only impossible
but futile in its attempt it verily
cannot be done
when an old man is able to defeat many
attackers how could it be due to his
strength we live in two realms two
dimensions the spiritual and the
material so to live an effective life
both aspects must be addressed the
spiritual contains the real power but
the natural is the trigger to release it
the two must work in harmony one of the
greatest gifts of the martial arts is
that they ultimately guide us to new
levels of spirituality always more vital
to karate then techniques or strength is
the spiritual element that lets you move
and act with complete freedom in
striving to enter the proper frame of
mind Zen meditation is of great
importance the man who wants to walk the
way of karate cannot afford to neglect
Zen and spiritual training but what
saith the word of God blessed are the
undefiled in the way those who walk in
the law of the Lord so how are these men
claiming to serve Jehovah and yet
walking after the steps of another
master spiritual development is
paramount technical skills are merely a
means to the end you may train for a
long time but if you merely move your
hands and feet and jump up and down like
a puppet learning karate is not very
different from learning a dance you will
never reach the heart of the matter you
will have failed to grasp the
quintessence of karate though
quintessence an interesting word the
fifth and highest element in ancient and
medieval philosophy that is said to
permeate all nature and all matter and
is the substance composing all celestial
bodies in physics it is the hypothetical
form of dark energy the fifth
fundamental force the fifth element and
by the ancient Greeks it was this force
which was thought to fill the universe
and hold and bind all things together
are we not hearing echoes of this same
philosophy in the media and films today
for my Ally is the force and apologies
[Music]
makes it grow its energy so how us and
binds us luminous beings are we not this
crude matter you must feel the force
around you you trade you me
everywhere yes even between the ship it
is this elusive spiritual energy which
the Taoist and Buddhist priests spend
their lives seeking to invoke and
harness are these mystical abilities
only the figment of the imagination of
Hollywood are they not mere fantasy and
make-believe but we must remember that
fiction often lies closest to the path
of truth else it has no power to deceive
since the beginning of Earth's history
Satan that old serpent has told mankind
that we have within ourselves the very
powers of divinity that we need look no
further nor higher than our own mind and
consciousness for the wisdom and powers
of a God and that through the join of
light with darkness and partaking of
that forbidden tree mankind may complete
the final step of his evolution into
godhood but the devil is a liar and the
father of all lies for it is through the
ministration of fallen angels that all
these miraculous feats of strength and
skill are achieved and it is for this
purpose alone that the devil entices men
women and even little children to
compromise with evil and thus opening
the doors wide to the power and
influence of the forces of darkness the
Hindu gurus have a word for this merging
of flesh with spirit it is called avatar
and literally means the manifestation of
the fallen ones or those which came down
from the heavens is this just
coincidence that a major film production
was recently released by the same title
and is this the reason we see such a
barrage of mystical teachings and
terminology in the media updates today
is Satan preparing mankind for the
coming of his final and greatest
deception one which the Scriptures
declare will if possible deceive even
the very elect with all power signs and
lying wonders the magicians of heathen
times have
the counterpart in the mediums the
clairvoyance and the fortune tellers of
today could the veil be lifted from
before our eyes we should see evil
angels employing all their arts to
deceive and to destroy
I saw the rapidity with which this
delusion of spiritualism was spreading a
train of cars was shown me going with
the speed of lightning the angel bade me
look carefully look carefully as I fixed
my eyes upon the Train it seemed that
the whole world was on board then he
showed me the conductor a fair stately
person whom all the passengers looked up
to in reverence I was perplexed and
asked who it was
he said it is Satan he is the conductor
in the form of an angel of light and he
has taken the world captain they have
been given over to strong delusions to
believe a lie and they are heading with
lightning speed to perdition this
delusion will spread and we all shall
have to contend with it face to face and
unless we are prepared for it we shall
be ensnared and overcome the people of
God must be prepared to withstand these
lying spirits with the truths from the
Word of God hi everyone thank you for
watching docket Tuesday and today you
are watching the Dragon revealed all
right so the Dragon revealed is of
course about martial arts what you're
watching that you're sending home and
you're thinking I should get some
exercise not just sit around well we
would encourage you not to do yoga or
Tai Chi or martial arts or things like
that what you're gonna find out
explained in this video and in part two
so if you want more information about
all those things Eric Wilson has put
together this I think six part series
that he did in Australia that goes into
detail about all these things you can
find this on little light studios TV or
on Vimeo and I think there's some kind
of promotion going on with this video
isn't there yes there is so every 1,000
views we get on this documentary we
get 10% off of digital downloads on
female alright and if we get to 10,000
views will leave the documentary up for
an extra day for every 10,000 views for
a week until next dock or Tuesday when
we release another title that's awesome
so don't forget to like and share this
video with your friends and your family
and if you like what we're doing you can
help support us on patreon for as little
as $5 a month you can get early access
and behind-the-scenes access to what
we're doing and there are other levels
as well where you can get exclusive
t-shirts like a producer T course we
make our own t-shirts designs you can
check those out on teespring
and thanks for watching and we hope you
enjoy the rest of the video
Yoga to yoke or to join in union with
the Hindu gods through the martial arts
Tai Chi and yoga a door is being open
for the introduction and the acceptance
of many mystical practices when women
come together and you let go of the
judgment and you just be together as
women and breathe together as women all
truths come out ritual happens
connection
Yoga is the state where you are needing
nothing when you feel whole and complete
I would say it will save your life it
will change your life it will make you
so much more accepting of yourself Yoga
has in the last few years really
exploded for Americans a lot of folks
swear by its and Christians though
believe there's actual real problem with
yoga Mike Alana is here with today's get
to the point saying where you bring us
these hot-button topics dealing with
morals faith values what do we have here
all right let's find out Erica mentioned
it's big 17 million of you out there
practice yoga but again Erica mentioned
it some Christians one in particular
says a Christian should not do yoga is
Pastor John MacArthur he is pastor of
Grace Community Church also host of the
radio show grace to you he joins us now
bottom line basically you can't get the
physical benefits without incorporating
the spiritual roots of yoga we'll talk
with John MacArthur in just a minute
also joining us a pastor complete
disagrees it says hey doing yoga is okay
Doug Padgett his Church in Minneapolis
actually offers a class in yoga but
let's start with you John MacArthur all
right let's say I do decide to try yoga
and head to the local gym give it a shot
what am i opening myself up to
spiritually that could go against my
Christian faith well that would depend
on how the yoga is conducted if it's
just purely exercise and you're a strong
Christian probably wouldn't have any
impact on your faith but in the big
picture
why would Christians want to borrow an
expression from a false religion from
pantheism God is everything your God
everything is God when we believe
there's only one true God the God and
father of our Lord Jesus Christ why
would we need to import that if you want
to exercise exercise but why borrow a
term that has been part of a false
religion for centuries
Doug Penn Jillette's gets you in on this
and as we do want to read the definition
from Webster's on yoga it says it's a
Hindu theistic philosophy teaching the
suppression of all activity of body mind
and will in order that the self may
realize its distinction from man and
attain liberation kind of tough one
decipher but on on a spiritual front for
a Christian that does not sound like
Christ centered fake to be on the
surface of that
definition what's going on here help us
out well for people who perform yoga
what they're normally trying to do is to
find a whole and complete and healed
life so when people participate in yoga
most of them are not some kind of a yoga
agenda what they're trying to do is use
whatever practices they can find that
would help them have a whole incomplete
life and for a Christian that's
certainly what we're after the the Jesus
agenda is a whole life is a complete
life as a healed life so when people use
it to relieve stress to be healthy and
the relationships to feel good in their
body that's a really good thing is all
yoga bad Yoga for the Christian well let
me just respond but what I've been
hearing that doesn't sound anything like
Christianity if you want a whole life if
you want your life to be what it should
be you don't put yourself in some weird
physical position empty your mind Center
on yourself and find a really trying to
relieve your stress
you go to the Word of God to the gospel
of Jesus Christ
you embrace in faith the sacrifice of
Christ and his death and resurrection as
your Savior and Redeemer God comes
regenerate you transforms your life
makes you a new creation and you're
saved and you're on your way to heaven
and you can live a life a peace and joy
that's the promise of the gospel that
there is no contribution made to that by
any physical position or any kind of
meditation the idea of Christianity is
to fill your mind with biblical truth
and focus on the God who is above you
that's Christian worship the idea of
yoga is to fill your mind with nothing
except to focus on yourself and try to
find the God that is inside of you from
a Christian viewpoint that's a false
religion and it is the goal of all yoga
practice regardless of name or
methodology to relax the body to open
the mind and let down the guard and it
is that which the Hindu Yogi's called
the great serpent spirit' according to
ancient Hindu texts this spirit lives
within care
the human being from birth thus inviting
this spirit to awaken from its coiled
slumber below the navel and climbed the
spiral staircase to the throne of the
human will a throne which is said to
reside at the third eye or frontal lobe
of the human mind within every human
lies a divine cosmic energy called
Kundalini almost every tradition speaks
of it in one form or another in Japanese
it is called ki in Chinese it is called
Chi the scriptures of Christianity call
it the holy spirit what is Kundalini it
is the power of the self the power of
consciousness Kundalini is Shakti the
supreme energy whom the sages of India
worship as the mother of the universe
it is only when the Kundalini is
awakened that we become aware of our
true nature of our greatness of the fact
that not only do we belong to God but we
are God when one acquires the strength
of Kundalini one no longer remains a
bound limited creature one achieves
total union with God but which God are
they speaking of to it I don't think
that there's a way to close your world
again once it's opened its open one of
the wonderful things about you
as a practice is that we really become
connected to our offense itself you go
back to the mat every day because it's a
practice and you want to see the
miracles that unfolded let me so often
in a physical polls in asana
you'll breathe in and suddenly
everything will be clear people are
trying constantly to find peace to find
that power to find inspiration their own
inner beauty it's no coincidence that
Yoga is really popular today because the
world needs yoga right now the reason
why so many people practice again is
because it tastes good thus the martial
artist and yoga practitioner is said to
achieve enlightenment and Nirvana
beginning the path to immortal life but
this is that same lie which the ancient
serpent spoke to Eve in the Garden of
Eden thus saying that by faithless
disobedience and rebellion to the word
of Jehovah and partaking of that
forbidden fruit of the tree of knowledge
of good and evil he shall not surely die
but ye shall be as gods Satan wove an
elaborate web of deception twisting and
distorting the word of Yahweh and today
the very same lie is being spoken
through the sensei's gurus masters and
instructors of the Eastern mystical arts
taste and see they say for in the day ye
there of your eyes shall be opened and
ye shall be as God's knowing both light
and darkness good and evil
is this the enlightenment which Jesus
lived suffered and died to give his
people is this that mystery which he
rose again from the dead the third day
to freely impart now I beseech you
brethren I would have you wise unto that
which is good and simple concerning evil
this is the ultimate purpose of the
Eastern mystical arts the joining and
merging of humanity with the forces of
darkness millions are being deceived by
the ancient dragon as they are told that
we are on the brink of the final
evolution of mankind and in this final
step we will achieve godhood as man is
delving into the occult practices of the
Eastern religions in his effort to see
beyond the veil of our physical world
the doorway is being open to spiritual
forces and powers of which the Bible has
warned us in no uncertain terms
spiritualism takes many forms in the
Eastern arts but all of these regardless
of how they are clothed are but the
working of demons upon the human mind
the Greek word for sorcery is a magician
or an oriental scientist do we not hear
many of these occult skills now falsely
being called science although these
esoteric skills were once reserved for
only those who had spent their lives in
the dark arts now in the end of this age
when the powers of darkness see that
time has almost run out the dragon is
working to make these abilities not only
desirable but available to all who are
willing to yield to his voice and take
that step onto enchanted ground here are
the word of the Lord o house of Israel
thus say of Jehovah learn not the ways
of the heathen and be not intrigued by
the signs of the heavens for the heathen
are dismayed at them
thou shalt not learn to do after the
abominations of these heathen nations
there shall not be found among you
anyone that maketh his son or daughter
to pass through the fire or that use a
divination to
or an enchanter or a witch or a charmer
a hypnotist or a consulter with familiar
spirits nor a wizard or a necromancer
one who speaks with the dead for all
that do these things are an abomination
unto the Lord Yahweh practices which are
rooted in the pagan religions of the Far
East are now becoming popular among
health and medical communities which
claim to be healing rather than
combative in nature and that which was
once called witchcraft only fifty years
ago is now being widely accepted as an
alternative form of medicine cloaked in
garments of pseudo scientific
terminology many health food stores
chiropractors and even Western medical
doctors are now incorporating
traditional Chinese medicine and ancient
Hindu healing techniques as part of
their practice acupuncture acupressure
arrow veda iridology energetic
kinesiology reflexology magnetism and
hypnosis are now being recommended as a
safe means to recovering and maintaining
health but we would do well in taking
heed to jehovah's instructions to avoid
profane and vain babblings and
opposition's of science which are
falsely so-called today many Christians
are turning back to Egypt in seeking
relief from pain and physical disease
rather than simply seeking help from the
Word of the Living God the mysteries of
heathen worship are being replaced by
secret associations and seances the
obscurities and wonders of
spiritualistic mediums and the
disclosures of these mediums is being
eagerly received by thousands who refuse
to accept light from god's word
believers and spiritualism may speak
with scorn of the magicians of old but
the great deceiver laughs and triumphs
as they yield to his arts under a deaf
or more modern form the Apostles and
followers of nearly all forms of
spiritism claimed to have power to cure
disease they attribute their powers to
electricity magnetism the so called
sympathetic remedies or to the latent
forces within the mind of man there are
many who shrink with horror from the
thought of consulting spirit mediums but
who are attracted by the more pleasing
forms of spiritism forms such as the
Emanuel movement Christian Science
theosophy and other oriental religions
through a flood of spiritualistic
teachings from Hollywood and the printed
page Satan is working in this final
generation with a fierceness such as
never before the dragon is fighting to
blind the eyes and the minds of all
mankind so that we might not see and
comprehend the glad tidings of Christ
which is according to the scriptures the
power of God unto salvation to everyone
that believes working through
infiltration rather than by a direct
frontal attack millions are now being
swept away into a religion which
requires no blood atonement no cross no
personal sacrifice no death to self the
world or their flesh for if our gospel
be hid it is hid to them that are lost
in whom the god of this world has
blinded the minds of them that believe
not lest the light in the revealing of
the glorious glad tidings of Christ who
is the image of God should shine unto
them
so it will be in the great final
conflict between righteousness and sin
while new life light and power are
descending from on high in the latter
rain upon the disciples of Christ a
strange force is springing up from
beneath and energizing the agencies of
Satan intensity is taking possession of
every earthly element and with a
subtlety gained through centuries of
conflict the Prince of evil works under
it
guys he now manifests himself clothed as
an angel of light in the days of Christ
the leaders and teachers of Israel were
powerless to resist the work of Satan
for they were neglecting the only means
by which they could have withstood the
evil spirits for it was by the Word of
God that Christ overcame the wicked one
and it is by His Word that we also are
to overcome and they overcame him by the
blood of the Lamb and by the word of
their testimony and they loved not their
lives even unto death for with the heart
man believes unto righteousness and with
his mouth profession is made unto
salvation the leaders of Israel
professed to be the expositors of God's
Word but they had studied it only to
sustain their traditions by their
interpretation they made God's Word
express sentiments that God had never
given their mystical construction made
indistinct that which the Lord had made
plain they disputed over insignificant
technicalities and practically denied
the most essential truths and thus
infidelity and the seeds of doubt were
scattered everywhere God's Word was
robbed of its power and evil spirits
worked their will today history is
repeating with the Bible open before
them and professing to reverence its
teachings many of the religious leaders
of our time are destroying faith in it
as the Word of God they busy themselves
with dissecting the word setting their
own opinions above its plainest
statements in their hands God's Word
loses its regenerating power and this is
why infidelity runs riot and iniquity
grows so widespread
and so it is that when satan has
undermined faith in the Bible he then
directs men to other sources for light
and power thus he insinuates himself
those who turn from the plain teaching
of Scripture and the convicting power of
God's Holy Spirit are thus inviting the
control of demons criticism and
speculation concerning the Scriptures
have opened the way for spiritism in
theosophy those modernized forms of
ancient hedonism to gain a foothold even
in the professed churches of our Lord
Jesus Christ for side by side with the
preaching of the gospel agencies are
working which are but the medium of
lying spirits many a man tampers with
these merely from curiosity but seen
evidence of the working of a more than
human power he is Lord on and on until
he is controlled by a will stronger than
his own many church leaders of every
denomination are now being trained in
what is called spiritual formation
practices which have been taken from the
works of Eastern mystics and Ignatius
Loyola and these men are now leading our
churches in the acceptance of an
emerging new form of Christianity
through the practices of lectio Divina
contemplative prayer centering prayer
meditation spiritual drumming and other
ancient spiritual exercises for me zazen
is free to come into the presence of
mystery
and sit with attention and attention
reverence gratitude need not be spoken
we don't have to use the words what
would I do with words what I'd like to
remind God of something God forgot when
you can really be mindful of this
present moment and recognizing that its
depth it's mystery is deeper than any
thought you have that any feeling that
you have it's hard to find words for
this that's when you feel that you are
held that you are sustained that what
you really are is deeper than what you
think you are
or than anything anybody says you are
it's deeper and that reality is the
Christ spirit that reality is our Buddha
nature that's who I media
many honest Christians are now being led
into the snare of that old serpent and
the apostasy foretold by the Holy
Scriptures in these last days now the
spirit speaketh expressly that in the
latter times some shall depart from the
faith giving heed to seducing spirits
and the doctrines of devils
but this know also that in the last days
perilous times shall come
for men shall be lovers of their own
selves having a form of godliness but
denying the power thereof I tell you
from such turn away all of these
practices are deeply rooted in the
occult philosophies of asia's three
primary religions and each of these
religions share five common principles
or doctrines the first being the
doctrine of reincarnation and the
immortality of the soul
the second is pantheism the teaching
that God is an energy or force which
resides within all matter
the third is known as the principle of
the divine spark or the godhood of all
mankind waiting to be revealed through
pagan and occult
initiation the fourth principle is the
doctrine of evolution the teaching that
mankind is only a higher form of animal
not created in the likeness of God but
in that of the brute beasts and now
slowly evolving through spiritual
exercises into godhood and the fifth and
most fundamental of all is that
principle of yin and yang the belief of
the dualistic nature of all things that
there are no absolutes and each of these
five teachings stand in direct
opposition to a clear thus saith the
Lord today they are coming in to
educational institutions and churches
everywhere spiritualistic teachings that
undermine faith in God and in his word
the theory that God is an essence an
energy or force pervading all nature is
now being received by many who profess
to believe the scriptures but however
beautifully clothed this theory is a
most dangerous deception it
misrepresents Jehovah and is a dishonor
to his greatness and majesty it tends
not only to mislead but to debase men
for darkness is its element and
sensuality its sphere the result of
accepting this philosophy is separation
from God and a fallen human nature
this means ruin these spiritualistic
theories concerning God make his grace
and divine influence of no effect for if
God is an essence which pervades all
nature then he dwells in all men and in
order to attain holiness man has only to
develop the power within himself these
theories if followed to their logical
conclusion sweep away the entire plan of
salvation they do away with the
necessity for the atonement and they
make man his own Savior these theories
regarding God make his word of no effect
and those who accept them are in great
danger of being finally led to look upon
the whole Bible as a fiction the
Spiritual Exercises of Ignatius resound
with almost identical philosophies as
those of the Hindu Taoist and Buddhist
religions the occult principles of his
writings are being taught not only in
yoga and Tai Chi classes but now also in
many contemporary spiritual retreats as
well as spiritual formation and emergent
church leadership programs
it should come therefore is no surprise
that the Roman Church has even
recognised Buddha as one of her own
under the name st. Joseph ad for the
word Catholic literally means universal
and as the universal church she welcomes
with open arms all religious beliefs
into her fold so long as they recognize
the Roman pontiff as the highest
spiritual authority upon this earth so
what is the purpose and gathering into
one all the religions of the world and
how is the art of war being used to
promote a
and years of peace and in the latter
time of their kingdom when the apostasy
has come to the full a king of fierce
countenance and understanding dark
sentences shall arise and his strength
shall be mighty but not by his own power
for the Dragon shall give him his power
and his throne and great Authority and
he shall destroy marvelously through
signs and wonders and shall prosper and
shall accomplish and he shall destroy
the mighty and the holy people and
through his knowledge also he shall
cause craft treachery subtlety and
deceit to prosper in his hand and he
shall magnify himself in his heart and
by peace he shall destroy many church
members love that which the world loves
and are ready to join with them and
Satan determines to unite them in one
body and thus strengthen his cause by
sweeping all into the ranks of
spiritualism papist who boasts
themselves of miracles as a certain sign
of the true church will be readily
deceived by this wonder-working power
and Protestants having cast away the
shield of truth and faith in the word of
God will also be diluted papist
Protestants and whirlings alike will
accept the form of godliness without the
power and they will see in this union of
grand movement for the conversion of the
world and the ushering in of the
long-expected millennium and what is
this message which is to prepare mankind
for a coming new age of peace in order
to have world harmony all mankind must
acknowledge equality of all faiths one
cannot be said to be better or worse
than another
neither can one be said to hold the
truth and all others be in error all the
religious leaders and founders of every
age must be recognized and acknowledged
as divinely inspired and all influenced
by that same
spirit are we seeing this happen in the
media today when I was 10 years old I
asked my mother I said well there's only
one God why are there so many religions
and over the years I've been pondering
that question ever since and it would
seem to me that the conclusion I've come
to is that all the religions are true
they just see a different part of the
elephant
[Music]
according to the grandmasters and the
founders of the Eastern arts the
ultimate purpose of all martial systems
is peace first it is said by creating
peace or harmony between heaven and
earth within the man and then in
creating peace between all of mankind
with the crisis facing our world today
through continued and ever larger
natural disasters the crumbling of
financial empires epidemic outbreaks of
disease and plague bloodshed famine and
war Humanity is searching desperately
searching for an answer to this world's
dilemma a solution to the world's
calamities a safety in the coming storm
a savior
if you will to lead all mankind into a
thousand years of peace and just such a
beam will appear one who is clothed in
light and manifests himself with
miraculous powers of reconciliation
healing and peace he has been expected
for generations by all of the major
religions Christians know him as the
Christ and expect his imminent return
Jews await him as the Messiah
Hindus look for the coming of Krishna
Buddhists expect him as matreya
Buddha and Muslims anticipate the Amon
Mahadi
although the names are different many
believe they all refer to the same
individual the world teacher whose
personal name is matreya world peace
must develop from inner peace peace is
not just the absence of violence peace
is the manifestation of human compassion
the very name Matri means
loving-kindness in today's world we
really need metree matreya
loving-kindness are these just the
sentiments of a few new-age mystics or
is there a spirit working behind the
scenes to bring all the world to
there is one 1997 in Washington DC dr.
sung young moon established the martial
arts Federation for world peace for the
purpose of building world peace by
encouraging all martial artists to work
together it has tried to transcend all
differences that exist between people
who practice martial arts the Federation
respects all martial arts and is
dedicated to bringing about unity and
cooperation for a bigger purpose namely
world peace since war begins in the
minds of men it is in the minds of men
that defenses of peace must be
constructed from my own personal
training and experience
I think the first steps toward world
peace is personal peace one thing about
this organization that I find very
interesting is its emphasis on the
concept of creating a moral Society a
strong Society because of my experience
in Asia the original martial arts were
formed for the purpose of creating a
safe and stable Society the martial arts
are truly a unifying force in our
troubled world today aside from religion
itself the martial arts comprised the
one philosophy which brings the inner
goodness and strength that everyone
possesses to the surface both in one's
own life and to inspire the best in
others why can't all the people of the
planet live together in harmony
I just don't know there have been three
big walls that have caused Wars
throughout history they are national
religious and racial walls the day the
people of the world agreed to construct
one universal country one universal
religion and one universal human race by
everyone becoming colorblind
everyone on this planet will be happy
with every breath of life it is
interesting to note that in order to
obtain peace these men practice fighting
and in order to gain Armony within the
martial arts teach combat domination
pride and control however if we practice
fighting in order not to fight if we
practice striking in order to develop
self-control if we practice retaliation
in order not to retaliate there is
something terribly wrong with our
spiritual worldview this is exactly the
product of the eastern taoist Buddhist
and Hindu philosophies the fruit of that
forbidden tree for light becomes
darkness error becomes truth and that
which is declared as evil by the word of
Jehovah has now looked upon as being
good the teachings and doctrines and
practices of the martial arts Tai Chi
and yoga are in direct opposition to the
Word of God and through these arts man
is being led into rebellion against his
creator by transgression of God's holy
law and his instructions in
righteousness we are bringing upon
ourselves in all the world to shore
results of our own arrogance and pride
humanity under the influence of that
great serpent the devil is striving to
revive the ancient empire of the Sun and
under global cooperation to rebuild a
temple to the gods and a place upon its
throne a new world leader a teacher who
will guide all mankind into a thousand
years of peace but of the times and
seasons brethren you have no need that I
write unto you for you yourselves know
perfectly that the day of the Lord so
cometh as a thief in the night for when
they shall say peace and safety security
then sudden destruction cometh upon them
as travail upon a woman with child and
they shall not escape
this end of an age inevitably produces a
certain number of natural disasters such
as floods in earthquakes and we are
seeing a dramatic climax in the number
of disasters taking place around the
world Matt Reyes says the last time I
came as Jesus it was written in the
Bible that when I appeared again the
very elements of nature would be
disturbed after the disasters have
peaked there will come a period of calm
the violence and destruction will come
to an end as people gain awareness their
guilt will receive but ye brethren are
not in darkness that that day should
overtake you as a theme for ye were
sometimes darkness but now are ye light
in the Lord walk then and live as
children of the light let no man deceive
you by any means for that day of the
Lord shall not come except there come a
falling away an apostasy first and that
man of sin the transgressor of jehovah's
law be revealed the son of perdition who
opposeth and exalteth himself above all
that is called God or that is worshipped
so that he as God sitteth in the temple
of God showing himself that he is gone
the Protestants of the United States
will be foremost in stretching their
hands across the Gulf to grasp the hands
of spear
they will reach over the abyss to clasp
hands with the Roman power brothers and
sisters letha's protest is over is yours
in 1999 this was signed by the Lutheran
Church through Federation worldwide
later but five years later the worldwide
Methodists signed the same agreement but
as of today we still have had no
Protestant evangelical that will stand
up and sign this agreement and under the
influence of this threefold Union this
country will follow in the steps of Rome
in trampling on the rights of conscience
as spiritualism more closely imitates
the nominal Christianity of our day it
has greater power to deceive and to
ensnare Satan himself is converted and
after the modern order of things he will
appear as an angel of light through the
agency of spiritualism miracles will be
wrought the sick will be healed and many
undeniable wonders will be performed and
as the spirits will profess faith in the
Bible and manifest respect for the
institutions of the Roman Church their
work will be accepted as a manifestation
of divine power I told you
aha yeah whoa I'll tell you I'm
now heaven is thrilled over this
[Music]
[Applause]
to me I mean when we went into the
ministry 47 years ago this was
impossible the closing chapters of the
book of revelation tell us that there
will soon be one final stand between the
children of light and the forces of
darkness and it is for this last great
and decisive battle that the dragon is
preparing his armies for not alone while
Satan in his fallen angels fight for
dominion of this earth men also will
have their part to play and truly this
can be seen all around us today through
the medium of secular literature popular
magazines video games music and movies
we are witnessing an entire generation
of men women and little children being
conformed into the image of this fallen
world and through the avenues of the
soul many are yielding themselves to the
influence and control of demons little
do they realize the forces working
behind the scenes for their destruction
and it is these spirits once exalted as
angels of God who are now joining and
working within the hearts and minds of
the children of disobedience for they
are the spirits of Devil's working
miracles which go forth unto the kings
of the earth and of the whole world to
gather them to the Battle of that great
day of God Almighty fearful sights of a
supernatural character will soon be
revealed in the heavens in token of the
power of miracle-working demons the
spirits of Devil's will go forth to the
kings of the earth and to the whole
world to fasten them in deception and
urge them on to unite with Satan in his
last struggle against the government of
heaven by these agencies rulers and
subjects alike will be deceived through
the martial arts yoga and Eastern
mysticism the door has been open to the
spirits and religious practices of the
and now in this final generation the
dragon is tempting all mankind to taste
of that forbidden tree the knowledge of
which brings darkness guilt shame and
bondage to sin through the modern media
popular fiction Eastern healing
techniques and the practices of
spiritual formation that old serpent the
devil is blinding men's eyes to the
absolute Verity and unfailing truth of
God's word of the character of our
Father in heaven and of his great love
and power to set the captives free by
casting his shadow between men and the
light shining from the pages of the
scripture Satan is seeking to destroy
men's faith in jehovah's word and thus
severing him from his only means of
salvation Redemption deliverance and
healing it is through the blending of
light and darkness truth and error good
with evil that the dragon is leading men
in open rebellion against our Creator
and through the transgression of his
holy law
Satan is preparing all mankind for his
last great deception an event prophesied
by Scripture which will take the whole
world as an overwhelming surprise but
today the door of Mercy is still open
and the Lord is calling to every man
woman and child if he will only hear his
voice he is saying my son my daughter
give me your heart choose ye this day
whom you will serve but as for me and my
house we will serve the Lord
[Music]
you